[Música]
a lo largo de la historia de la
humanidad las sustancias con potencial
adictivo nos han acompañado
tenemos referencias desde algunos grupos
étnicos que usan plantas o algunas
hierbas que tienen efectos alucinógenos
y que esto ayuda a que puedan consolidar
sus creencias o hacer vínculos con las
deidades tenemos referencias como el uso
de la hoja de coca para aumentar la
energía y poder lograr actividades o
incluso el uso de la metanfetamina en la
segunda guerra mundial cómo surge esta
droga para que los soldados sean mejores
más agresivos no duerman no coman y
puedan ser más eficientes
actualmente que vemos
consumo de múltiples sustancias debates
entre criminalizar legalizar prohibir
políticas encontradas la realidad es que
nos topamos cada vez con mayor número de
drogas o de sustancias de potencial
adictivo para el 2016 se reportaron
aproximadamente 480 y tantas nuevas
drogas de abuso y todavía estamos
enfrascados entre sí legalizar o
prohibir alguna u otra sustancia hace
algunos años yo creo que ustedes
recuerdan se vino como un auge sobre
luchar contra la obesidad sobre todo en
los niños y decían esto tiene mucho que
ver con las golosinas y las papitas y
los refrescos y empezaron a prohibir los
en las escuelas y aparecieron los
carteles de los niños que traficaban
papitas
y es curioso porque cuando uno se topa
con estas situaciones se da cuenta que a
veces estamos más preocupados por el
resultado que por el origen
en la política normalmente escuchamos
sobre todo en salud que llegan
personalidades que tienen que ver con la
cuestión de la salud pública y llegaron
hospitales en la acabamos de nombrar
este hospital como un centro libre de
humo de tabaco
yo recuerdo una información como un
médico cuando uno pasa de esta etapa del
internado
o no llega a durar hasta 48 horas sin
dormir y es parte de la formación así
son los médicos 48 horas sin dormir
y tienes que estar listo porque tienes
que estar en alguno de los servicios
sacando sangre o revisando algún
paciente y el problema es que se empieza
a cabecear ya te tomaron una foto y
ahora la suben al facebook y dice miren
al flojo 48 horas sin dormir con un
sistema militarizado jerárquico que si
la persona que está arriba de ti tiene
una mala opinión por una mala palabra
algo que no le gustó que respondiste en
una pregunta te quedas de castigo otro
día más sin dormir
y que veíamos
en la madrugada o temprano antes de
cabrear al servicio
estaba el estacionamiento lleno de
médicos y enfermeras fumando tomando
café tomando coca-cola para poder
resistir la siguiente jornada
y ahora llegan a prohibir el consumo de
tabaco en el hospital
en vez de pensar por que fumaran más los
médicos las enfermeras
no la solución es prohibir el tabaco
imagínense cómo está nuestra mente
también en la parte de estima que
podemos escuchar algún día en la mañana
que un tráiler chocó se llevó cinco
carros tuvieron días muertos y nuestra
opinión primero hacia las personas que
manejan trailers no es muy positiva
aparte de mujeriegos les ponemos muchas
otras cosas
pero después si aparece y le encontraron
metanfetamina en sangre
eso es como terminarlo
y cuando nos ponemos en sus zapatos que
tiene que tener jornadas altas y
entregar el producto con doble carga con
un remolque que no está hecho para lo
que era y que si no no le pagan y tiene
hijos
pero la opinión pública es que él es un
adicto
entender esta vinculación del fenómeno
del consumo no puede ser tan simplista
esto de decir que todas las personas que
consumen es porque sienten un placer y
el consumo recreativo
la línea está tan mal dibujada
que partamos por esto el término
adicción ni siquiera existe en los
sistemas de clasificación de
enfermedades
la oms la organización mundial de la
salud tiene este sistema llamado
clasificación de internacional de
enfermedades dentro de este grupo de
enfermedades existen las mentales ahí
aparecen los trastornos por uso de
sustancias que típicamente les llamamos
adicción y los englobamos a todos en uno
y son tan diferentes
y pareciera ser que alguien diría bueno
es que eso es muy especializados yo
porque tengo que saber cuál es el
término médico psicológico psiquiátrico
porque en base a esa clasificación es el
abordaje que vamos a hacer en prevención
en tratamiento
inclusive en cuestiones que van más allá
como la reinserción social
y tenemos casos típicos de la
adolescente que tiene trastorno por
déficit de atención hiperactividad
estos jóvenes que les llaman índigos
mendigos y no sé qué tantos nombres les
ponen que no se pueden estar quietos que
se distraen fácilmente y que cuando
llegan a la preparatoria o la
universidad tienen que estar grandes
jornadas poniendo atención a un estímulo
muchos de ellos en un sistema educativo
donde los profesores no tienen la
formación o no tienen las habilidades
para enseñar o con salones saturados de
muchachos en los cuales cuesta más
trabajo poderse enfocar en un solo
estímulo y con esta enfermedad con este
padecimiento para que poder fijar su
atención en un punto y que se distraen
con todo con la mosca con el que hablo
con el radio con el celular y quieren
mantener su enfoque en el centro de
repente se da cuenta que dando dos
caladas a un cigarro de marihuana
se enfocan mejor
y en la noche cuando está en su cama y
se quiere dormir y está pensando en una
cuatro o cinco cosas el ventilador y no
puede dormir se da cuenta que tomando
alcohol o fumando marihuana duerme mejor
entonces empieza a fumar marihuana
y su mamá dice no va muy bien en la
escuela probablemente por el déficit de
atención entré a su cuarto revisa y
encuentra un churro de marihuana
y a quién va a preguntarle normalmente
y cuando llega con esta persona le dice
yo que tú lo llevaría a un centro de
tratamiento aquí al lado hay uno de
personas de estos de doble-a donde te
pueden dar opinión llega y el padrino en
turno dice si es un caso típico de ese
que ve en el avión por la marihuana
anexen lo
y el muchacho que fuma marihuana una vez
al mes a lo mejor ya está anexa 2
donde conoce gente que consume otras
sustancias que tiene otros hábitos y no
hay que ser un genio para saber cómo
sale
y todo por no hacer una buena
clasificación no todo el que consume es
un adicto no todo el que consumen lo
hace por placer mucha gente consume
muchos de aquí probablemente consumimos
algo que es dañino para nosotros y es
para compensar algún problema que
tenemos
la organización mundial de la salud
recientemente acaba de postular que ya
adicción a los videojuegos en línea
imagínense cuántas señoras van a llegar
y va a decir doctor creo que mi hijo es
adicto a los videojuegos porque porque
está jugando todo el día no sale no es
otra cosa y una pregunta señora y su
hijo puede salir a la calle a jugar no
está muy peligroso tener otros niños a
la casa gobierno porque el bullying está
gordito y no me lo vayan a marear y
ustedes conviven con él no nos
trabajamos
entonces como carajos no quiere que el
niño esté metido en los videojuegos
cuántas personas que tienen un consumo
que les llega a generar problemas de
sustancias legales o ilegales pongan el
nombre que quieran
no es porque tienen otro problema
interno problemas de insomnio problemas
de depresión problemas de ansiedad
y la sustancia lo está mitigando y cada
vez que prohibimos estigmatizamos
estamos generando una revictimización de
estas personas
la línea entre una persona que consume y
que no tiene problemas al que consume y
tiene problemas y al que tiene la
enfermedad mental de la adicción
muy mal dibujada
estamos mezclando a las personas y
estamos haciendo intervenciones que no
son apropiadas no son trajes hechos a la
medida
pensemos como muchas recomendaciones de
la política pública más efectiva en
drogas dicen no criminalizar a los
consumidores perfecto el que consume el
que siembra en su casa en la marihuana
el que tiene un consumo recreativo no
vamos a criminalizar lo
pero ya aquel que su consumo ya genera
conductas delictivas
todavía hay un gran debate que dice el
doctor usted dice que si alguien consume
drogas comete delitos los está
criminalizando no no todo el que consume
drogas comete delitos pero hay muchas
personas que tienen características que
con solo agregar el alcohol o alguna
droga ilegal es más fácil que cometan un
delito
si no me creen hacemos un experimento en
el estadio azteca chivas américa
entrada gratis pero sólo vendemos
bebidas sin alcohol solo jugos o segunda
barra libre
porque hay más accidentes porque hay más
violencia porque hay más problemas
cuando está el alcohol involucrado
porque el alcohol y las drogas ilegales
afectan áreas del cerebro que están
vinculadas con las emociones con las
percepciones con la conducta y una
persona en estado de intoxicación puede
sacar algo que normalmente no haría
sobrio
y puede ponerse agresivo puede cometer
un delito como un robo
y por eso estos programas como el
impulso que se hizo hace algunos años
por el modelo de justicia terapéutica
para personas con consumo de sustancias
en méxico precisamente buscaba esto
personas que por su consumo cometían
delitos y como el envés de meterlo en un
sistema judicial o meterlo a la cárcel
buscar mitigar este consumo
y tratar los otros problemas de salud
mental puede disminuir la tasa de
delitos y tiene toda la lógica del mundo
no es criminalizar al que consume no es
criminalizar al que vende es tratar
estos factores como agentes que pueden
llevar a cometer un delito
méxico en las encuestas de hogares
aparece como uno de los países que
tienen menos consumo del mundo de la
media de la prevalencia del consumo de
drogas ilegales méxico aparece a la
mitad
si nos comparamos con eeuu somos una
décima del consumo que tienen ellos de
marihuana menos de la décima de que
tienen de metanfetaminas pero cuando lo
contrastamos con otros sistemas de
información como el sistema de
vigilancia epidemiológica en adicciones
del sisbén
no checan los datos
se tiene registros de más de 5000
centros de tratamiento en nuestro país
entre profesionales y no profesionales y
de grupos de ayuda no está más de 5000
tenemos tampoco consumo como hay tanta
oferta de tratamiento y el sisbén nos
habla de que el primer lugar de droga de
impacto ya en méxico es la metanfetamina
al cristal una droga altamente adictiva
altamente dañina para el cerebro y para
el cuerpo y estrechamente vinculada con
delitos
en algunas de las oportunidades que he
tenido de convivir con personas que
atienden gente que tiene problemas de
consumo en sonora me platicaba una
psicóloga en un hospital de tratamiento
de adictos del gobierno
y dice no es la anfetamina no es el
cristal son las metanfetaminas aquí
llegan los pacientes y te dicen pues es
que depende cuál es el cristal que esté
en la calle y en algún momento decían el
cristal que está ahorita en la calle te
hace violar
cuántas veces no escuchamos
entre voces que hay un alto consumo de
drogas dentro de las prisiones en los
gremios de la salud
pero nos estamos reportando
al llegar a un mercado regulado de
drogas implica una responsabilidad
tremenda de si el que está enfermo y
tiene una adicción tratarlo como eso y
darle los beneficios de un tratamiento
porque está enfermo y por eso consume no
lo puede controlar pero aquel que
consume a sabiendas de que le causa
problemas de una manera irresponsable y
que comete delitos como se va a atender
en el sistema típico de justicia
y otro aquellas personas que no han
consumido pero que tienen trastornos
mentales importantes como déficit
atención hiperactividad como ansiedad
personas que tienen una mala calidad de
vida que tienen pocos ingresos
económicos que tienen jornadas laborales
muy altas y que esperamos que
mágicamente van a ser felices cuando las
drogas a lo mejor era lo único que los
hacía felices
es un panorama bastante complejo y el
entender nos lleva a escucharnos a
escuchar al consumidor a escuchar a los
padres a escuchar a los maestros a
integrar la información pero de una
manera sistematizada y organizada y
sobre todo basada en la ciencia porque
cada vez más encontramos modelos de
prevención de tratamiento de reinserción
basados en la ocurrencia
se despilfarra dinero en programas de
prevención que probablemente su
efectividad sea mínima esta idea de que
una persona por solo saber los daños que
provoca una sustancia va a dejar de
consumir es absurda
las personas con problemas más graves
del consumo de sustancias los adictos
más fuertes no están en los hospitales
no están en los centros profesionales
están en los centros de las asociaciones
civiles
y muchas veces son víctimas de
violaciones de los derechos humanos
queremos cambiar este problema queremos
hacer un giro a la política de drogas
preguntémonos primero dónde estamos cómo
está nuestra población y que podemos
hacer poniéndonos en los zapatos de los
consumidores y respetando los derechos
de los demás
gracias
[Aplausos]